[Music]
in tragic boat tour news submitted by
adopt me a tour boat carrying 12 people
exploded in the Bahamas another 12 the
same 12 yeah what I was 13
yo a tour boat carrying 12 people
exploded whoa what it explode what
happen yeah so this is crazy
um one person died and that person that
died she was actually celebrating 15
years wedding anniversary with her
husband on a tour boat yeah was it one
of those boats that are like pretty
small and then you kind of see like
whales and [ __ ] and fish and it's like a
dinner cruise well that's like a CG
picture yeah it looks like some
old-school Miami Vice [ __ ] and then a
[ __ ] they're chasing a drug lord and
their boat blew up yeah damn but twelve
only one person died and then one person
died I think it was nine people were
injured like seriously injured oh yeah
we saw this on the news the other day
and some girl lost your legs or side
dancer and lost really that's her job
what irony in this I don't like it
she's never gonna dance again whoa
guilty feeding got no rhythm wanted but
the feed ain't guilty here the feat was
fun that's just tragic man that's absurd
ah [ __ ] yeah so [ __ ] her legs had to be
amputated below the knee
she could still dance this is where it
happened
baloney you know what the technology for
like prosthetics and [ __ ] is getting
pretty good so I really really hate
centered process it's just not a big it
really a hope for you yeah yeah he's
like you know the technology for
prosthetics and [ __ ]
he's just trying to bail out all the
water on his own bit cuz he's cuz he
said guilty she doesn't even have feet
anymore
nope he's never she's never gonna dance
again and then I continued the lyrics
right but I'm saying he's like taking on
a lot of water so he's like trying to
bail out his little [ __ ] he's like whoa
there's a lot of really great
prosthetics actually as you can probably
dancers Bart straight up with a shaky so
dance yeah there's so many [ __ ]
runners in the Paralympics with like no
legs that's true yeah I mean yeah let's
keep the that'll be a really good story
for her too it's like there's someone's
gonna make a documentary about her life
I was a dancer and then like you know
how hard the dance industry is like [ __ ]
man there's so many people that are like
even after 50 [ __ ] for the
choreographer they still can't get
through you know so there's a huge line
and [ __ ] and then everyone's trying to
be the [ __ ] Cirque show or whatever
right 50 [ __ ] shut up you've never
heard of that I didn't know that was a
thing that's how to get gigs thank you
sir
you never heard of me - I'm pretty sure
dancers homie it ain't so Jabbawockeez
tell me it ain't so what about the
backup dancers you don't think you don't
think that it happens I think it happens
all the time
I feel like rappers line up dancers and
[ __ ] whip out their dick and slap
every single but cheek I believe it fair
chance for everyone out there
wait you swear you've never had sex with
a video ho yeah swear put your [ __ ]
hand up and uh no no no a backup dancer
you won't know but I'm not like oh like
you got to do this to get this gig how
do you know good transaction I seriously
you know actually verbal how do you know
your casting director didn't do it well
I'm gonna have to have a talk with my
casting director you know which is
myself I feel like you got taken
advantage of because it's probably a big
chance that someone sucked you off and
then six months later you remember how
that [ __ ] was and you're like you
know what you dance won't you come in my
video that's it right now you know it's
a whole like fit the groupie kind of
situation too right like the thing I
don't like to get like if it's a groupie
like okay I'll hook up with you but if
you're like a superfan nobody feel like
a superfan gender rights I don't like to
mix that you know man if you're a fan
and you want to hook up with me you
better like being aggressive like oh now
you know girl you got oh I would never
like cross that line if you're just like
a fan you know I mean like yeah but what
if they [ __ ] you 10 times harder cuz of
they really care they're a fan there's
super thick as dough and only [ __ ]
know well so far verbal about that to me
I usually don't you know I read the
energy but we're talking about we're
talking I'm feeling your energy and yes
I will [ __ ] you uh it just depends on
the intensity of the [ __ ] energy but
then there's three gargoyle Alleluia he
show me uh can you show me a really
intense [ __ ] energy like he's putting it
out right now no he's not good feelin no
can you show me oh I I don't know I
can't do it but then I feel the [ __ ]
Joey he's like the Miss Cleo of groupies
like I sense that you want to [ __ ] me I
never felt it like that sometimes you
know people very internal like
introverts right you don't know but you
see into the I go you're trying to [ __ ]
today oh damn you see them their eyes oh
it's just me hoping that and then I just
manipulate the situation but in most
cases they're like I don't want to I
don't want to [ __ ] it always like I read
that wrong the energy was off please
please don't tell anyone about this I
have a career just as they please not I
uh I don't really I don't go too much
like I really do keep that thing except
I now be on tour is it good for you
wait you but you said that you fought
groupies you just don't [ __ ] fans yeah
yeah there's a difference you know I
mean there's a difference between two
groupies no because bees don't even
listen to your [ __ ] or like fans of your
[ __ ] really what
[ __ ] you they just want to like hook up
for like that status do you trying to
use you for the [ __ ] so they could
proclaim that they did you yeah I think
there's a difference between fans and
groupie so when you're [ __ ] a groupie
and if they're like can you listen to
your own music obviously and they're
kind of mounting the lyrics you like
whoa whoa whoa I thought you were a
groupie you know my channel a groupie
pal you know my cattle pow-pow
yeah will you put up that wall yeah have
to ask you to leave man here's my
merchants take get out of here dick out
of your body and get the hell out of
here
get your dumbfounded fan ass out of this
room right now we did a show once and
there was these three crazy like
extra-large gargoyles that were really
drunk and have bad alcohol breath and in
there like where you steer a super
aggressive dude or like what are you
staying tonight cuz we want a party and
I'm all [ __ ] gargoyles there's no
reason why you should be worried because
offended I worry I'm like you [ __ ]
gargles you know who the [ __ ] I am
goddamn relax I was like call them
gargoyles not hot he's the ass parts in
the corner bars as I get them because
I'll be like I'll tell you later I don't
remember you think it's funny everyone
didn't laugh cuz that should probably
would happen although you did get one
thing right when you were jerking when
you're pretend to be depart Durkins
Dickens they look very small and very
little move hey I like your title right
squeeze it hard it's like the Bob Barker
Mike on The Price is Right really long
but then just held by two fingers excuse
you I'd like you to know that I love is
dick it's perfect but it'd be perfect
like this oh nice good for you anytime a
girl says my my man's dick is perfect
they're covering it up it's a euphemism
for saying that is small that's not good
Jess just says my dick is small camera
you just did I love it I don't care cuz
it's not my size that's making me feel I
feel girls are mad honest with that [ __ ]
like girlfriends and stuff I feel like
they never like overdo it they're just
like yeah it's a good size would be like
it sucks like good I'm just saying y'all
are very honest like honest straight-up
honest you just have to say it like it's
perfect yeah I don't even want to talk
about this story that's very sad it's
more fun talking about this what's
tragic bunch of people died in a boating
thing no no because I didn't yeah I
don't know what to say about that sad I
don't even know bulk a bird on life is
there more information
I mean Stephanie I believe me double
check yeah Stephanie and Stacy so they
both are the Persephone she's so pretty
the dancer and this is her mom oh they
look like sisters my mom
the boy they're both in ICU and then her
little sister was also on the boat along
with her husband hot dogs and they're
fine I don't see in pictures of people
man because then a really humanize this
is the couple that were celebrating the
anniversary she pass
yeah god that is so crazy Nutella tragic
yeah it's really hey hey hey we made
jokes before we saw their faces we
didn't even make jokes about this stuff
we don't know what jokes we told you're
the only one who made jokes like this
yeah what am I talking about he's like
we made jokes no no you made a joke hey
get back here you made the joke I was
putting them on the spot that was fine
yeah you know the craziest thing though
I'm burning in hell then we all are not
also Stephanie the dancer right now
she's in a medically induced coma and so
she doesn't have legs she doesn't even
know Oh No when she wakes up she's gonna
wake up and we start a Kickstarter and
get hurt can we just get like help them
promote the kick no because what I want
her to have is better like better legs
did she used to have because that's how
good technology is [ __ ] happening
these days is like what is gonna happen
Jews not yea though she's gonna yeah
eventually
robot babies get real good one because
she's still young she still it's gonna
reach 200,000 cuz for the for both the
mom and the daughter and then the the
husband or the dad and a brother they're
like Oh what happened to the mom she's
she had like a broken rib or like other
she's just that's so sad that the dancer
element is just like that's just so sad
I know what couldn't it be like a burnt
ear or something like it's it's a
[ __ ] leg dude that's what she needs
for work and passions both of them
that's [ __ ] up dude damn I don't even
know what to do I'd be like I don't know
man I'd be so sad that'd be like if your
lips got burnt and seal
you [ __ ] your lips got blown after my
MERS I have to learn how to toss to mind
always like mm-hmm hey it's working
because that [ __ ] what's funny it's
pretty close
no but it's it's close so you have to
you have to cut it open and then stick
this cuisine
I always find that match rally to
somebody losing with like you know when
the fines can the money may get exactly
damn man that's crazy because being a
musician yourself what if you lost your
freaking vocal cord or worse what if you
lost rhythm completely oh [ __ ] you
rhythm this rapper yeah all of beaten
[ __ ] that's horrible
there's a lot of rhythm with rappers
already it's kind of a trend right now
actually
[Music]